tenemos aquí un ejemplo de los
ejercicios del sitio de khan academy
esto es descomposición de fracciones con
denominadores de 100 y aquí dice usa la
imagen siguiente para completar la
ecuación la ecuación dice 26 centésimas
es igual a estrella décimas más 6
centésimas ahora se nos está dando esta
recta numérica y en ella vemos que aquí
está el 0 0 décimas es lo mismo que 0 y
llega hasta 26 centésimas así que veamos
si esto tiene sentido tú aquí puedes ver
que entre cero décimas y una décima hay
una división de diez espacios que tienen
el mismo tamaño es 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
entonces si tú divides una décima en
décimas cada una de éstas será
equivalente a una centésima una
centésima es una décima de una
así que tenemos una centésima dos
centésimas tres centésimas cuatro cinco
seis siete ocho nueve diez centésimas 11
12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 centésimas 21
22 23 24 25 26 centésimas entonces 26
centésimas es justo lo que tenemos aquí
tenemos que 26 centésimas es igual a
estrella décimas más 6 centésimas y 6
centésimas es esto que tenemos aquí
agregado en color verde si contamos
sabemos que son 1 2 3 4 5 6 centésimas
entonces a qué equivale esta flecha que
tenemos aquí en color rosa podríamos
decir que es igual a 20 centésimas
porque si contamos vemos que son 10 20
centésimas o podríamos simplemente decir
que son dos décimas
entonces 26 centésimas es lo mismo que
dos décimas más seis centésimas dos
décimas más seis centésimas nos lleva
justo aquí por lo tanto tenemos que
estrellar es igual a dos estrella es
igual a dos y terminamos